JoJosée Legault, Stéphanie
ChChouinard et Alec Castonguay.
BoBonsoir à vous trois.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Depuis dimanche,
dedepuis ce lien entre le
rarapatriement du pouvoir à Quéc
susur la réunification familial,
1212 000 personnes à peu près pr
anannée, dont la moitié ne parle
papas français, donc depuis que.
LeLegault a fait ce lien et la
susurvie du français, la
lolouisianisation, c'est repart.
MaMais c'est plus large que ça,n
vovoit que le débat est relancé
susur les migrations. Je vais vs
fafaire entendre avant de
didiscussion M. Legault qui a
paparlé aux journalistes matin.e
fafais suivre ça tout de suite
apaprès avec un échange entre le
PaParti libéral et Simon Jolin-
BaBarrette.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Ce que je voulais dire,
c'c'est qu'on peut pas prendre
unun exemple, même trois exempl,
pupuis à partir de ces exemples-
llà, dire : tous les Québécois
ququi arrivent ici et qui
coconnaissent pas le français
apapprennent le français.
- - La langue parlée à la maiso,
c'c'est pas les affaires
dudu premier ministre.
SISIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE, ministre
reresp. de la Langue française,c
- - Lorsque, Monsieur
lele président, ils vont
alaller travailler ensemble
susur les lieux de travail,
ilils s'expriment en français.
LoLorsqu'ils vont aller se réunr
popour une partie de soccer,
auau hockey, dans l'espace publ,
auau magasin, lorsqu'ils vont
alaller faire des achats,
MoMonsieur le président,
ilils vont le faire en français.
LoLorsqu'ils vont aller souper
enensemble et que c'est des
lolocuteurs de langues maternels
didistinctes, ils vont utiliser
lele français.
SASAUL POLO, porte-parole du PLQ
enen matière d'immigration
- - Il a brandi, hier,
l'l'épouvantail de la Louisiane
popour créer un effet de
didiversion, pour créer plus de
didivision au sein des Québécoi,
etet ça, c'est inacceptable.
QuQuand est-ce qu'on va être
asassez québécois?
- - C'est grave, ce que le dépué
dede Laval-des-Rapides dit.
ToToute personne qui est
auau Québec est un Québécois,
etet ce que les Québécois veule,
c'c'est que notre lien en commu,
cece soit le français.
- - Le client moral de
l'l'immigration n'a jamais incls
lala langue parlée à la maisono.
SiSi c'est vers là qu'ils veulet
alaller, ils vont nous trouver.
IlIls ne vont jamais nous retirr
cece droit-là.
- - Le Québec est une des sociés
leles plus accueillantes et
leles plus ouvertes dans le mon.
MaMais au Québec, on doit
acaccueillir en français
leles personnes immigrantes.
PuPuis vous savez, Monsieur
lele président, l'expérience
dudu Parti libéral au pouvoir,
çaça a été de négliger
lele français.
- - Ça, c'est un échange, il y n
auaura d'autres, je vous ferai
écécouter d'autres extraits plus
tatard, mais on commence avec ç.
M.M. Polo qui dit : moi, je peux
pepeut-être encore parler la
lalangue que je veux chez moi,
mamais ailleurs je parle frança.
JeJe vous montre le tableau des
lalangues parlées à la maison.
7474 % en 2036 et Langley qui
auaugmentent. Et la langue
ututilisée le plus souvent au
trtravail, c'est Langley. C'este
dedernier tableau, mesdames et
memessieurs, je vous rassure.
1818 % pour l'anglais à Montréa.
JoJosé, est-ce que ce débat s'en
vava dans la bonne direction?
- - Pas pour le moment, ça c'est
cecertain. Vous savez que ma
spspécialité universitaire c'est
lala question linguistique.
J'J'ai beaucoup étudié le sujet,
j'j'avais même cosigné le premir
rarapport en 1996 qui allumaient
dédéjà des voyants gens là-dess.
J'J'ai les pressions de revivren
jojour de la marmotte. Si je pex
vovous dire le fond de ma pensé,
j'j'ai écouté très attentivement
lele point de presse de M.
LeLegault, j'ai même vu la
trtranscription pour être sûr qe
j'j'avais bien entendu. J'avais
imimpression d'assister à un
mamauvais cours de linguistique.
IlIl expliquait les transferts
lilinguistiques. Parce que c'est
çaça, les transferts linguistiqs
àà la maison. C'est de manière
totout à fait normale.
MaMais au Québec, ça prend des
lolois. Mais il avait de la
didifficulté, il ne maîtrisait s
leles concepts. C'est le rôle de
soson ministre Jolin-Barrette de
fafaire cette démagogie. Ce n'et
papas le rôle du premier ministe
dede toute manière.
UnUne dernière chose que j'ai d,
c'c'est qu'il manque un Gérard
GoGodin dans ce gouvernement. On
sese rappelle sous René Lévesqu,
mamais il y avait aussi un petit
pepeu après, Gérard Godin il étt
miministre de la migration et ds
cocommunautés culturelles.
AuAujourd'hui on appellerait çaa
didiversité. C'était quelqu'un i
avavait des antennes dans les
cocommunautés culturelles, qui
avavaient une sensibilité et qui
raramenait ça à son premier
miministre. Monsieur Legault, il
n'n'a pas ça non plus.
AlAlors il y a des choses qui
mamanquent.
- - Pour éviter...
- - Au-delà des stratégies
popolitiques, il y a des chosese
babase qui manque.
- - Pour éviter que des gens se
sesentent montrés du doigt, 60
cocomme si on leur disait que vs
êêtes responsable
inindividuellement, que les chox
ququ'ils font individuellement e
sosont pas les bons.
StStéphanie, Alex période Québe,
c'c'était intéressant.
QuQuel est votre regard sur ce
dédébat qui reprend?
- - On trouve ça problématique,
susurtout de s'attarder sur la
lalangue qu'on parle à la maiso.
QuQuand on entend parler de Simn
JoJolin-Barrette qui parle
d'd'immigrants qui vont parler u
rerestaurant. Il faut se rappelr
ququ'au Québec, le français esta
lalangue publique commune, et
c'c'est tout à fait compréhensie
etet souhaitable qu'on amène les
imimmigrants à parler la langue
pupublique commune. Mais d'être
bibilingue ou trilingue, ce n'et
papas un crime. Il y a quelque
chchose de tout à fait louable e
ceces individus veulent passer
leleur langue de maternelle à
papasser leurs enfants.
CoComme les francophones
exextérieurs du Québec.
EtEt donc, c'est cet aspect quee
trtrouve absolument problématiq,
ququ'on oublie que de parler
frfrançais, ça se fait avec
d'd'autres langues, incluant
l'l'angalis.
MaMais aussi qu'on ne peut pas
s's'immiscer dans la vie déjà.
CÇa devrait aussi être vu comme
unune richesse qui appartient au
QuQuébec.
- - Allègue, sur la
lolouisianisation, Monsieur
LeLegault a quand même nuancé, l
y y avait le discours politique
papartisan dimanche, mais
auaujourd'hui il dit...
d'd'ailleurs, c'est une expressn
ququ'on a entendue plusieurs fos
dadans les sports du Québec.
OnOn a les pressions qu'il n'a s
vovoulu faire le lien direct ene
lele rapatriement du pouvoir des
imimmigrants... La réunification
sese familiale et la survie du
QuQuébec. De se sortir de cette
éqéquation qui était peut-être n
pepeu trop simple.
- - Et qui était nettement
exexagérée.
IlIl y a aucune loi pour protégr
lala langue française là-bas. Iy
a a jamais eu 30 % de francophos
llà-bas en Louisiane.
AuAu dernier recensement, 94 %
didisaient qui pouvaient mainter
unune conversation en français.
CÇa n'arrivera pas au Québec peu
imimporte la lorgnette comprend.
C'C'est difficile à comprendre n
pepeu au centre le gouvernement
avavec ça, parce que... La lange
paparlée à la maison, ça c'est s
dedes statistiques qui ont
bebeaucoup de valeur.
EÉvidemment, si on immigrants
ararrivent ici, il va continuerà
paparler sa langue à la maison.
S'S'il est capable d'évoluer das
leles espaces publics en frança,
çaça va demeurer la langue comme
popour tous et ils vont être,
leleurs enfants et, francisé.
C'C'est comme si le gouvernement
n'n'avait pas confiance d'abordn
seses propres programmes de
frfrancisation, et si c'est le
cacas, ils ont à mettre plus
d'd'argent là-dedans, et leur
prproprere loi 96 qui vient tout
jujuste de passer, avec des
momodifications.
IlIl y a l les exigences d'avois
popostes bilingues qui devront
êêtre plus encadrées, parce que
c'c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'd'entreprises qui exigent des
popostes bilingues à Montréal
alalors qu'on devrait pouvoir
ococcuper ce poste même si on
paparle seulement français.
C'C'est comme si le gouvernement
sosoudainement disait qu'il n'a
papas confiance en sa loi 96, et
seses programmes de francisatio,
alalors il faut vraiment qu'il e
coconcentre sur les personnes qi
ararrivent chaque année sur la
réréunification familiale, comme
sisi cela était une menace danse
grgrand tout de la langue
frfrançaise au Québec.
C'C'est ça qui à un positionnemt
popolitique, parce que ça ne tit
papas lala route d'un côté
ststatistiques.
- - José, la fin de la
réréunification familiale, commt
avavez-vous pris ça?
- - Comme une maladresse.
C'C'est que le premimier ministe
enenvoie dans plusieurs directis
enen même temps, ce n'est pas
totoujours très clair.
MaMais si je peux revenir, parce
quque je trouve ça très triste,a
meme fait revivre ce que j'ai vu
2525 ans sur la situation du
frfrançais. Les transferts
lilinguistiques, c'est quoi? C't
lolorsqu'une personne immigrant,
papas cette personne, mais peut-
êêtre ses enfants ou ses petits-
enenfants, peuvent bien garder a
lalangue maternelle, mais pour a
lalangue d'usage en général à la
mamaison, au travail, éducation,
adadopte la langue officielle, a
lalangue de la société. Ça se ft
totout seul pour Langley au Cana
ananglais. Ça ne se fait pas tot
seseul au Québec. Ces statistiqs
ququi se fait chaque année.
AuAu Québec, le problème, c'est
quque... les transferts
lilinguistiques, ne sont pas das
unune proportion suffisante pour
asassurer que le français demeue
àà long terme une langue
dodominante.
EtEt j'exclus la minorité
ananglophone, qui a ses droits t
seses institutions.
CÇa, c'est le seul endroit au
CaCanada où la langue officielle
d'd'une province est concurrence
papar une autre langue, c'est-à-
didire le français est concurreé
papar l' anglais.
DaDans le Canada anglais, ça
n'n'arrive pas.
EnEn politique, ça ne s'explique
papas facilement. Ça prend des
spspécialistes, ça prend des
pépédagogues, et c'est pour ça e
c'c'est en train de prendre des
prproportions. On fait croire qe
leles taux veut aller dans le
sasalon des gens pour mesurer
ququ'est-ce qu'ils parlent dans
leles salons. Je m'excuse, mais
c'c'est Statistique Canada qui
memesure ça.
- - Mais pour finir, José,
vovous dîtes que les indicateurs
dede langue parlée à la maison,
popour vous, vous dîtes que c'et
imimportant, parce que ça dénote
s's'il y a eu un transfert
lilinguistique complet?
- - Voilà.
IlIls peuvent garder leur langue
mamaternelle aussi, mais ça
n'n'exclut pas l'autre langue.
MaMais qu'est-ce que vous voule,
cece sont des débats
lilinguistiques, et lorsque ça
rerentre dans le domaine
popolitique, bien la, on voit qe
çaça... mais je trouve ça vraimt
trtriste que l'on commence à nos
fafaire croire que le français a
êêtre sauvé seulement si on le
paparle de manière publique, ce
n'n'est pas vrai ça. C'est un
trtravail de longue haleine come
ilil se fait de manière naturele
papartout au Canada anglais.
- - Le vrai débat, c'est le nome
d'd'immigrants qu'on reçoit au
CaCanada, qu'il disait hier.
JeJe disais, que si le Québec en
rereçoit beaucoup et que le Cana
rereçoit moins, le foie va
babaisser. Ou si on reçoit plus,
c'c'est dangereux pour la langu.
IlIl disait : c'est ça le vrai
dédébat qu'on arrive pas faim.
ToTour de table rapide sur ça.
CeCe n'est pas ça le vrai débat?
- - Oui. Ce qui est compliqué ds
cece débat, il y a un aspect dea
lalangue, mais il y a aussi les
asaspects de la croissance
écéconomique en relation avec le
trtravail, la pénurie de main-
d'd'oeuvre. Au Canada anglais,
JoJosé a raison, on n'a pas les
mmêmes tiraillements avec la
lalangue. On peut accueillir pls
d'd'immigrants, avoir plus de
mémédecins formés, parce qu'on
pepeut former.
TaTakagi 54 000, maintenant...
onon est dans une fourchette qu,
dede toute façon, faire en sorte
ququ'on va avoir moins de poidsu
CaCanada, parce qu'on est renduà
40400 000 par année dans le rese
dudu Canada, donc c'est énorme.
DoDonc oui, cette espèce de
titiraillements n'est pas facilà
rérésoudre. Je pense quand même
bebeaucoup... sur les compétencs
dede certaines catégories
d'd'immigrgrants qui arrivent ii
ququi devraient déjà parler
frfrançais.
MaMais il faut qu'on en accueil.
SiSinon on va voir un déclin
dédémographique complet.
- - C'est comme s'il y avait dex
momots. Stéphanie?
- - Oui. D'une part, j'aimerais
didire que langue distillation s
imimmigrants ne se fait pas en
clclaquant des doigts. Il y a un
prproblème dans certains
cocommunautés, ce qu'on appelle
ghghettonisation.
CeCe n'est pas vrai que ça se ft
dede manière automatique dans le
CaCanada anglais malgré... ce st
dedes problèmes différents que
cecelui-là auquel le Québec fait
faface. Mais il ne faut quand me
papas sur simplifier. Sinon, coe
lele dit Alec, évidemment, le
QuQuébec a un enjeu particulier,
leles tâches québécois domaine e
la vente plus de soutien pour
acaccueillir les immigrants, por
leles francisé,
popour ce que ce n'est pas déjà
fafait, dans le cas de la
réréunification familiale, on vt
quque c'est une proportion
imimportante.
MaMais si les économies
ququébécoises continues de
crcroître, à moins d'avoir des
popolitiques familiales qui sur
papassent celle qui existe déjà,
etet qui sont déjà plus généreus
àà de nombreux égards que ce
ququ'on retrouve dans le reste u
papays, je ne crois pas que le
QuQuébec va s'en sortir.
- - José?
- - Les migrations, ce n'est pas
seseulement important pour des
raraisons économiques, c'est
imimportant pour le tissu socia.
C'C'est important d'avoir des
sosociétés diversifiées.
EtEt ça, ça compte pour quelque
chchose. Mais en même temps, au
QuQuébec, il faut préserver la
lalangue française.
IlIl faut marier ces deux
nénécessités.
EtEt oui, ça prend plus de
prprogrammes de francisation. M,
j'j'aurais étendu la loi 101 au
cécégep sans la moindre
héhésitation.
MaMais ça traîne aussi à cause e
cece choc, cette concurrence de
l'l'anglais, cette concurrence i
n'n'a pas dans le Canada anglai.
IlIl faut plus d'immigrants qui
mamaîtrisent le français, ou qui
paparle une langue qui est proce
dudu français. Mais ça prend un
mémélange tout ça. C'est très
cocomplexe au Québec.
- - Ça prend du temps pour faire
dedes débats intelligents là-
dedessus.
- - Bien moi, la...
- - c'est ce qu'on souhaite au
cours des prochains mois. Il y
auaura une campagne.
UnUn mot en Ontario, Stéphanie.
C'C'est réglé pour la première
plplace, à moins d'une gigantese
susurprise. Est-ce que ça vous
didit, il ne parle à peu près ps
auaux journalistes?
- - D'une part, du côté des
prprogressiste-conservateur, ona
fafait une campagne très cyniqu.
CÇa a été presque la loi de le
memettre. C'est-à-dire que les
cacandidats et les candidates sr
lele terrain ont fait très peu e
dédébats et d'apparitions
pupubliques. Ça été la même choe
popour Doug Ford qui a très peu
paparlé aux journalistes.
LeLes autres bacs pour la 2, Ple
etet ont passé plus de temps à
s's'attaquer les uns les autres
quque d'attaquer Doug Ford.
- - Merci beaucoup!
OnOn a prie le temps de parler e